[موسيقى]
هذا حل
يعمل في انسجام
مع الطبيعة الأم ، فهو يقبل
المياه التي تأتي بها مياه الفيضانات وتذهب إلى
أسفل المنزل ،
وتوفي مئات الأشخاص في إعصار كاترينا
والعديد من الأشخاص الآخرين فقدوا كل
شيء وكانت تجربة مؤلمة للغاية بالنسبة
لهم  لقد أصبحت تجربة مؤلمة
بالنسبة
لي وهذا ما ألهمني لمحاولة
التوصل إلى حل من شأنه أن
يمنع هذه الكارثة من
التأثير على هؤلاء الأشخاص.
يأتي الفيضان
بدلاً من الجلوس هناك ويمتلئ
بالماء ،
يكون له طفو تحته
وتوجيه عمودي بجانبه بحيث
عندما يأتي الفيضان يمكن أن يرتفع فوق
سطح الماء يطفو فوق
الماء ولكنه لا يطفو بعيدًا بسبب
التوجيه الرأسي
وبعد ذلك عندما ينحسر الماء ،
يعود لأسفل بلطف ويجلس على أساسه الأصلي
تمامًا كما كان قبل
الفيضان
[موسيقى]
ما أنا عليه  محاولة القيام بذلك
هو جعل هذا الحل
الذي
يمكن للسكان المهمشين تنفيذه
لأنهم هم الأكثر
حرمانًا
بسبب الفيضانات ، لقد
طورت
حلاً غير
مكلف للغاية وسهل
التثبيت لي مفهوم السدود والسدود
وجدران الفيضانات  اختيار معركة مع
الطبيعة الأم ،
أنا سعيد جدًا لأنني
طورت حلاً
يعمل بالتزامن
مع الطبيعة والمياه والأرض ،
إنه لشرف كبير أن يتم تسميتها من قبل إكسبو باعتبارها
واحدة من
أفضل 50 ممارسة عالمية
للتكيف مع تغير المناخ  هو حقا
لشرف كبير لي
[موسيقى]
لك